um
so the talk today i'm going to be
talking about two of my favorite things
at the moment uh blazer and tailwind css
just to give you a bit of an idea of of
kind of where this talk is aimed at i'm
going to assume you know a bit about
blazer i'm not going to go into sort of
real fundamentals about blaze or
anything like that
the focus of this talk is kind of you're
interested in tower wind and how do i
put tailwind and blazer together because
tailwinders we're going to discover is
slightly different to something like
bootstrap
so um just before we go any further just
a quick slide about me so my name is
chris
i'm a principal software engineer for a
startup in london called deployed
um
i'm also a microsoft mvp i've been one
for about three years now
um i do or i have done a lot of blogging
on blazer
but i haven't been doing much for about
a year and a half because
i decided to write a book because i
thought that would be a good idea and
that was a year and a half of my life
gone um
so so yeah but that that's done now and
hopefully that will that should be going
to print in the next sort of few weeks
so so that that's uh yeah that's that's
good and finally i do do quite a lot of
open source work so i have an
organization on github called blazid
um
got some of the most downloaded packages
of their type for blazer applications at
the moment which is quite nice
so the biggest one is blazer local
storage but we have modals and toasts
and things like that and we've just hit
a really big milestone recently we've
just gone past four million downloads
which um
is is scary because that means four
million people are relying on my code
which is
uh yeah that's interesting um but it's
also nice to see that blaze is growing
in popularity with that sort of um
uptake so so yeah anyway
that's enough about me
let's get into
the actual main topic here so
let's talk about tailwind csf to start
off with and what tell when css actually
is
so
tailwind css is a utility-based css
framework
so what does it mean to be a
utility-based css framework
well
let's draw a comparison with uh a sort
of another well-established framework
bootstrap
arbor class bootstrap is a
component-based css framework now what i
mean by that is that with bootstrap
you're going to
you know you're going to want to create
a certain button and you're going to in
order to do that with bootstrap you're
going to apply a class that's called
button or button primary or button
secondary or something like that and
that's going to have a pre-made style
for that type of button
there's also more advanced things like
cards and things where they have set
layouts and again you apply a class of
card and certain markup in a certain
structure and you get that look as well
utility frameworks are very different to
that
with utility frameworks there are
hundreds or thousands of very atomic css
classes what they usually do is is
target one specific css property and you
compose these together to create the
look you want
now what this means is that you get a
much more customized ui
we've probably all uh
can tell a bootstrap website from a mile
away it's it was kind of a meme at one
point
that doesn't really happen with tailwind
because there aren't any pre-made styles
that's also possibly a trade-off for you
depending on how much you're into ui
design or whether you work with a design
team okay
one thing that's also really interesting
about
utility frameworks and tailwind
specifically
is that you pretty much
never write css
which is an interesting concept
in fact i'll make you a promise at this
point in this talk i'm going to do a
load of demos and i'm not going to write
any css okay everything you're going to
see in this talk is going to be using
pre-made classes that are part of
tailwind
slightly i'm i'm running the line
slightly on that but i'll call that out
when i get there but
it's technically true
so let's have a look at what i mean by
this anyway and let's have a look at a
concrete example so this is uh the card
component from bootstrap's website okay
so this is what i mean by it being like
a component um so you apply this class
of card on the on the main outer div
then you've got these uh
sub elements with various classes on
them to style that card in a particular
way and this is a bit customizable you
can do the card without the image you
can uh miss out the the card text if you
want to and just have the title it it's
up to you there's a version as well
where you can have a button on there and
what have you but the point is
you're constrained by what bootstrap's
provided for you you have to use that
markup and you have to use those classes
so what would this look like when we
were doing this with tailwind well
this is the same card it looks the same
but the classes are different
so
what we've got on that that outer div
now are
very focused classes
designed to create the look that we want
so
flex is saying that we're going to use
flexbox for the layout here flex coal is
about the directions that's the flex
direction property that's saying him we
want this to be a column which means the
image and the div are going to get
stacked horizontally
there's a shadow you can just see there
on the bottom of that card so
we put shadow lg large shadow okay
the image you probably can't quite make
it out on hex is a bit small but there's
slightly rounded corners on the top of
that so that's what rounded t is rounded
top
h40 is saying there's a height of 40.
now 40 isn't actually 40 pixels or 40
rems it actually maps to a value in a
design system so i'm going to talk a bit
about that in a second
p4 again padding four that's going all
the way around again four maps to a
number in the design system and tex grey
800 that maps to a particular shade in a
color palette
then for the heading we've got text lg
text large font semi bold
and mv margin bottom two
so you can kind of hopefully start to
see that these classes are quite
readable once you kind of understand
what tailwind's naming conventions look
like
and this is kind of one of the cool
things i like about taowin because i
don't have to jump between a css file
and my markup file to understand how
things are styled i can just see it
straight here in my markup
so as i mentioned a second ago there
about those classes they mapped to a
design system while tailwind is
essentially a big design system
and this is quite an important thing
and the reason this is important is
because the time using the design system
puts us in a certain constraint which
means you can keep things looking
consistent and what have you
but you get a centralized way of
configuring it so
tailwind ships with a load of defaults
that are really good and you can build
really good stuff with them but if you
do want to customize them specifically
to your company
design language or anything like that
you can do
so if you're working with a design team
they can actually provide you sort of
your design language specifics you can
code them into towel wins configuration
and then the devs don't really have to
worry about the styling as such because
they just use the various classes and
they map to the right things in the
design system
so let's just cover a few of these off
so the color palette for example okay so
tailwind ships with a color palette with
about 22 different colors in by default
they range for various different things
and they all look like this they all
have a starting value of 50 and an upper
value of 900 and that's 50 being the
lightest shade 900 being the darkest
shade
you can then use
these then get mapped into
utility classes and you can use them for
various things where colors are
appropriate so
text purple 700 for example or bg gray
100 for background
has the same thing for spacing again i
appreciate that's kind of slightly tiny
but as i was mentioned a second ago
about that h40 not meaning 40 pixels or
40 rem
um it maps to a number in this design
system which is the first column and
then in the configuration file that is
then mapped to an actual value
so these are the values that come by
default
so for example four is one rem or 16
pixels
and it's a proportionate system so that
means that eight is double the size of
four essentially so it's a really good
sensible default and the nice thing is
here
what you kind of get away from
is just random arbitrary values um if
anyone's sort of built large scale apps
with custom css
you probably have seen what's happened
where you end up with classes that are
named very similarly because different
people have done it at different points
in time and not realized that a class
already exists
and then you've got say two cards
this one's got padding of 16 and this
one's got padding of 15
because 15 and 16 are almost
indistinguishable and no one knew it was
there before and you get these kind of
slight differences all over the place
but with tailwinds you'd just use four
and that would map to like say one rem
or whatever and if we ever wanted to
change that like say we wanted more
spacing by default you could just up the
value in the design system you haven't
got to go and change all your classes in
your markup code you just do it
centrally and boom everything goes goes
up
so again this can be used for various
things padding width height all that
kind of stuff
the other thing that is really cool
about tailwind is it's support for
variants so variants are things like uh
pseudo classes or media queries and
stuff like that
um
so again tailwind has a whole heap of
these that ship out of the box
um and then you can use them to do stuff
like hover effects or dark mode styling
or odd and even color variations on a
table or styling first elements or
whatever you you know happen to want to
do
and i think this is a really strong
selling point of tailwind because this
stuff is is a bit of a pain to do with
regular css you know if you want to
create a hover effect for a button you
know you're you're back in your css file
you're creating a duplicate of the class
with a hover sudo class on it and then
you're changing your styling and things
like that well to do the same thing in
tailwind we just say we want bg red 500
by default and when i hover over it
hover colon i want red
bg red 800 applied and that's it i've
now got a hover effect
i just want to really stress this all
this stuff is configurable there is
nothing in tailwind that is fixed
everything that's there you can change
you can modify you can adjust and you
can make it work the way that you want
to make it work but it's all optional
technically speaking you need to provide
no configuration to tailwind by default
okay you only need to provide
configurations for the things that you
want to change or that you you know you
want to tweak and personalize
so
a good way to think about
utility frameworks like towerwind is is
lego blocks for ui design
what you do is you compose these classes
together to create these looks and if
you don't like a particular element of
that
cool you just take out that particular
utility class apply a different one and
you can tweak that look and customize it
it's also a very rapid process like i
say once you learn the the naming
conventions for tailwind
you can very quickly iterate through
this and because you're not jumping
between uh css files and markup files
it's just a very rapid process
one of the main uses i think for taowan
when it first came out it got talked
around a lot being
sort of being used as a prototyping
framework for ui design because you
could just very quickly iterate on the
design
in a real app
just by quickly applying these utility
glasses
cool so let's get that little drink here
have a laugh at that while we're here
this is usually where people knew to
tell when start having a little twitch
if you're as old as me um and when you
when we started doing web design in in
the 90s and things like this
you'll know about inline styles and
you know we're all very much encouraged
to understand that inline styles are
evil and we shouldn't be using them
and tailwind does have a lot of
similarities with inline styles it does
look that way
um so let's deal with this head-on
what are the limitations of inline
styles why are they evil why shouldn't
you use them it's not like everything
it's not like you ever shouldn't ever
use them they have their place but
generally speaking
well firstly inline styles are just
magic numbers or magic strings depending
on what properties that you're putting
in there you're going to declare them
directly on an element by putting a
style attribute in there and they're
fixed to that element and if you want to
you know repeat those styles somewhere
else you copy and paste them over to
somewhere else if you want to change
them you're also going to go in and
you're going to have to change them
everywhere you've put them okay
there's no real way of centralizing
values and things like that to make sure
you're using consistent numbers or what
have you um colour codes things like
this so it makes maintenance very very
hard
pseudo states like hover and focus
they don't work with inline style so
goodbye any kind of nice interactive uis
with hover effects and what have you
you're not going to be able to do that
with with with inline styles
and probably one of the biggest ones in
modern web development is that you can't
use media queries so if you have an app
that needs to work on mobile devices and
tablets and desktops well
you're going to use inline styles then
you'll you're really out of luck that's
not going to work
so
darwin uses classes it's not inline
styles
they're just really focused
okay and that's the only difference and
that's where that kind of similarity
with with inline styles comes from but
that's it it just looks a bit similar
but all of the functionality that you
get with regular css you get with
tailwind
so
now we've kind of learned a little bit
about the basics of tailwind let's talk
about how we would actually start to use
tailwind with blazer
there's two options we're gonna we're
gonna look at
the first one we're gonna look at is
tailwinds play cdn so this is a new
uh a new thing that came out with
tailwind v3 which came out sort of tail
end of last year
um
and it's really quite impressive so in
order to use this um it's really really
quick and simple uh we add in a script
tag
um to the tailwind cdn
and then we just start writing our
our utility classes and it just works
okay
so really quick and easy to get going um
the thing i'd like to make clear at this
point is that
the tailwind guys are very very clear
about this this is for non-production
use okay so that's something to just be
aware of
it's kind of designed for people who
want to try out tailwind see what it's
like to use it maybe do prototyping that
kind of stuff but it's not something you
want to use for production apps okay so
that's why we're going to talk about the
second option in a second
but what's i think some of the coolest
bits about the tailwind cdn is that you
still get all the features that you
would have if you actually were running
this locally so you want to customize
the styles yeah that's cool that's not a
problem you can do that we add a script
tag we add a towel in configuration
object and we can just configure this
okay and that's going to do all of the
same configuration that you could do as
if you're running tailwind locally
so that's that's pretty impressive stuff
so
in this uh in this little code sample
i'm adding in a blazer purple color here
um and then i can just go and use that
so i can just go bg blazer purple and
that's just gonna work okay that's just
gonna build that on the fly now
just in case you're wondering how it
does this um that script tag is
basically going to process this and what
it does is it creates a style tag and
and basically puts all these styles and
injects them dynamically into the into
the host page
what's another cool feature of tailwind
is plugins so this there's various diff
well there's quite a lot of plugins
actually to tell when talwin has
official plugins and it also has
community plugins and they cover lots
and lots of different scenarios um and
you can even use some of these plugins
with the taowin cdn as well okay you
just put the plugins query string on
there and then you just say whichever
ones you want to use now you are limited
to the official taowin plugins to do
this
but you know the fact it does this at
all i think is is still pretty cool
um
so that's the cdn
um but i want to talk to you about
a different option which is the tailwind
cli
so this is uh what i would suggest you
use if you're actually going to build
real apps with tailwind okay
and
up to version three this was a an mpm
only thing you know you had to install
npm you used npm packages um which
sometimes in the dot net community
especially that that doesn't sit well
with people um
there's actually now a new uh option
here
so
the telling guys have created a
standalone cli now so it's a standalone
executable doesn't need node or anything
you can just download that from their
github releases page and you can just
yeah just reference it use it and it
just works you don't need to have node
or npm or any of that stuff
um
personally it's not the option i would
choose um because then you've got to
deal with getting that executable
somehow into your say if you're using a
ci pipeline you've got to get it in
there somehow and then run it and what
have you it becomes a bit of a faff
personally i do think the npm option is
the better option and i'm going to show
you uh using that today and frankly i
don't think it's too a particularly bad
option if you've got any other need for
npm if you need to do
i know say you need to do some
javascript bundling or something like
that for whatever reason because your
app might rely on it for for
for something um
you can plug that into that pipeline as
well so
um you'll be glad to know that's the end
of the slides now so
um we're going to go over to visual
studio and we're going to start having a
look at how we can actually build this
stuff
so
that's not changing
to do
aha there we go
um
so
what we're going to do is we're going to
work on a blazer webassembly app for the
rest of the session
so the first thing that we need to do
here is we actually need to get a
tailwind working with it so how do we
actually go about setting this stuff up
well
the first thing we're going to do is
i've got my terminal here and
i'm going to run
this command npx so i've got node
installed i've gone and got the
installer from node.js.org
um this mpx command a lot of people are
still unfamiliar with it it's it's quite
a cool thing i don't need a package.json
file or anything like that i'm just
going to say run this tailwind css
package
run the init command on it if i don't
have that in my in my node cache
it's going to go off and get it for me
and download it and run it if i've got
it it will just run it but it doesn't
create a node modules folder i don't
need a package.json file or anything
like that
so i can
hit go on that
that's going to go off and create this
tailwind configuration file so that's
now sitting at the root of my project
here
and this is
all that it creates okay
now
as i said technically speaking you you
kind of don't need to change anything
but you kind of really do
the one thing you need to do is actually
add something into this content
area here so we need to basically pass
into it
where what files are going to use our
tailwind utility classes
okay so we're putting in the path here
and this bit is just saying find any uh
files inside of our application that
have a razer or an html extension so our
blazer components and the host page for
our app
now the reason we're doing that is
because with tailwind v3 they move to
the jit engine by default
now
um what happened previously is that
taowin used to generate a load of
css classes when you first ran it
now they had to be quite selective about
what classes they generated because if
you turn on all of the features of
tailwind
v2 you would get about a 20 meg css file
and if you then try and load that in a
browser browsers get slow the dev tools
get slow it's not a very good
development experience so they gave you
some sensible defaults and then you just
turned on the other features that you
needed
but this wasn't really a great option so
they worked on this jit engine
and what this gt engine does is you
basically feed it the files that contain
are going to contain your your tailwind
utility classes it will monitor them and
every time you add a new class it will
dynamically recompile
the tailwind css for you so the tailwind
css will only ever contain the classes
that you're actually using but the cool
thing about this is that all of the
options that tailwind has available with
all of its pseudo classes and variants
and all this kind of stuff are all
turned on by default you just use the
class and it gets applied
so that's why we have to put this path
in here so that the jit engine knows
where to go off and look for these
these these classes
so that's our configuration file done
the next thing we're going to do is just
uh add in an
initial
input css file so i'm going to create a
styles folder here and inside of that
i'm going to add in a new style sheet
uh there we go
so we'll call this app css and inside of
here
we're gonna put in these three tailwind
directives so
towerwind is going to process this file
for us and it's going to create an
output css file that's going to contain
all of those utility classes
um
and basically these three directives get
processed and they generate various
different things so in the base layer it
generates a css reset okay so you get a
nice
level base before it starts applying all
of the various things it's going to do
then it generates component classes and
utility classes and this is
it's not really particularly important
to worry about what these mean but
essentially it's just kind of
making sure that the right styles can
override the right things and they're
all in the right order
so
that's our our input file so now we've
got that so we've always we've added
that tailwind configuration file and
we've added that input
css file
so in order to get going we then can run
mpx
and then we say tailwind css and then we
say
we're going to pass in an input file
that one that we just
created oh that's wrong
and then we're going to say we want to
output a file into our wwe root folder
and we're going to call that app.css as
well
and then at the end of it i'm going to
do this
additional tag minus minus watch so
what's going to happen here is the the
tailwind cli is just going to keep
watching
both that input file that styles app.css
and it's going to watch all of those
files we told it to watch all the razer
files and html files for changes all
right and every time one we modify
anything it's going to rebuild that
output file for us
okay
so we hit go
so that's now generated that that
initial file for us you can see there
146 milliseconds pretty pretty fast and
we can go and see that in here
so there's all the reset stuff that it's
generated and if we go down
it will start showing us
so now we can start seeing utility
classes okay and these are ones that
i've already got applied because i've
already done some work here because
watching me apply all these across a
whole site is going to be a little bit
boring for you so i've already done some
stuff uh to do this
so the final thing i'm just going to do
is quickly add a reference to that
output style onto the index page here
and now
let's see if we can have a look what
we've got
cool
so this is my reimagining of the the
default blazer template um i've been
working with blazer since pretty much it
it was first kind of conceived as a
experiment and i don't know about any of
you but i'm getting kind of quite tired
of the regular template and that purple
that purple gradient down the side so i
thought i'd have a little bit of a play
around and try and create something a
little bit more interesting
so this is what our starting point is
going to be but there's a few bits here
that need a bit more styling so i
thought we'll work through these
together just so you can get a little
bit of a feel of what it's like you know
to apply these
these tailwind classes
so
uh we're going to start by
going over to the index page
so it's my index component
now
i've got an h1 tag and a p class here
they haven't got any styles at the
moment so let's uh just go through and
add some of these in so
in order to do this
uh
the initial styling for this i'm going
to say uh
i want
a style on here of extra bowl because i
want my h1s to stand out a bit more so
i just uh hot reload go over so you now
see that that hello world has gone has
gone bold right i've just applied
that that first bit the next thing i'm
going to say is well i want it to be
quite big because you know this is a
heading after all so let's bump that up
as well so i want uh 7xl i want it to be
like really big text and boom i've got
really big text
um
i'm also going to say i want tracking to
be wider because
you know space things out a little bit
more make everything look a little bit
less
compressed
cool so i've got a little bit of spacing
now between the letters in my in my
words and finally i'm going to say i
want a margin bottom of six because it's
pretty close to that p tag so i can pop
that in as well
and well i've now started my h1 tag
now that's taken me sort of 20 or 30
seconds while i'm talking to you if you
can imagine if i'm actually coding this
up on my own i'm just going to be tap
tap tap tap tap done
and we can do the same thing for the p
tag here so the p tag here um i'm going
to say i want text xl and i want a
margin bottom of 20 on these because
that's how the styling is going to work
okay and now i've got like this really
huge massive text for my p tag okay
so
you can kind of see the process here as
developer you're just going to apply
these things you're going to refresh and
you get your styles and you're just
going to see very quickly what things
look like especially with tailwind's hot
reload and with blazers hot reload
system okay it's a very quick iterative
process
cool um
7x though it shouldn't have been quite
that big sorry my bad um
there we go that's what it should look
like sorry i thought i was looking a bit
big
nice so that's kind of just regular
styling okay which is pretty bland and
boring right that's pretty bad bread and
butter stuff
um
so how about something a little bit more
interesting um
so this panel on the right hand side is
looking pretty dull i want it to be kind
of a big feature of this it's kind of
taking up a lot of space and what have
you
um
so it'd be pretty cool does it tell when
logo's got a gradient how about we put a
gradient on the background right now
this is something that i always find a
bit of a pain in css i would consider
myself pretty confident with css but i
can never remember the syntax for
background gradients i always end up
googling this it's just one of those
things that won't stick in my head so
let's have a look at how we do this with
tailwind
so this div down here is the is the is
the outer div for that
so i'm going to apply three classes
these three classes here bg gradient to
br that's background gradient to bottom
right it's going to start in the top
left
and we'll say from green 400 to blue 500
okay so three classes
save that
do reload
and boom i've got a background gradient
okay
so pretty quick pretty rapid and i
haven't got i haven't had to open google
which is always a good thing
so that's a gradient but um let's have a
look at something else we could do with
this really rapidly so we've got our
background gradient stuff but how about
we just add a hover effect so we'll use
one of those pseudo classes hover and
we're going to say this time when we're
hovering we're just going to reverse the
gradient so we're going to say from blue
500 to green 400 instead okay same thing
but just the opposite way around let's
reload that go back over and boom now
i've got a hover effect on my gradient
as well
so these things are just pretty trivial
to do with something like tailwind okay
i'm not going off to separate files to
do this i'm not going to google to check
syntax okay all i've got to know is the
naming conventions that taowin has
the other thing that we'll just look at
as well uh just for for completeness is
the survey prompt here i've i've got as
an unstyled thing at the moment so
let's just quickly add some some base
styles in
so this now stands out a bit better this
looks a bit more interesting um
but we can even do sort of uh what i
would call more advanced things with css
with tailwind pretty trivially so
everything's really square on this page
and this is meant to be like a bit like
a banner thing so it'd be cool if it was
a bit skewed so it looked more like it
was kind of uh pasted on the page as it
were so how do we rotate elements and
transform them well
even stuff like that in town wind is is
is fairly trivial stuff i'm going to
reply two new css classes to to create
this effect
i'm going to reply transform which just
says i'm going to transform something
about this element's
position and then i'm going to apply the
rotate 3
utility class and this one if you'll
notice has a minus in front of it which
means i'm going to want to rotate
counterclockwise rather than clockwise
okay
so i'll pop that on there we'll reload
our app again and then we get a bit of
skewing
so
the reason i've showed you a few bits
like this is just kind of to show you
that sort of some things that are not
quite so trivial in regular css are
pretty trivial when you're using
something like tailwind you can create
some more advanced effects
with with not a lot of effort at all
so
at this point
some of you may be thinking about
repetition
okay so
those classes we've got on this h1 and
this p tag right usually these are the
sorts of things you want to be
consistent across your app you want all
your h1s to be the same you want all
your anchor tags to be the same right
am i going to have to go and copy and
paste this everywhere
because that doesn't sound like a lot of
fun
and i agree
so
even though tailwind kind of does uh
encourage you to put your styles
directly into your markup you can still
centralize styles for this kind of thing
okay so let's have a look at how we can
do that
so what we're going to do is if we go to
that input css file that we created
earlier
um we can uh use
a pretty cool feature of towerwind
called the apply directive
now this is where i said i was skirting
the line a little bit where i said i
wasn't going to write any css
so technically i am defining a class
here i'm defining the styles for the h1
type
but i'm not actually writing any css
properties out i'm just applying those
same utility classes using the apply
directive
so what's really cool about this is i
can centralize my styling for common
elements inside of here but i can still
leverage all the power of that design
system
all right
so if i go and change
the weighting of what extra bold is for
example on my on on the font that we're
using again i just do it centrally in my
design system i'm not coming here and
modifying it okay
so i can do that for the h1
and i can do that for the p tag okay we
can save that
that's all good and if we go back over
to our markup we'll get rid of the
uh styles that we added before we're
just going to
have our regular hth1 and p tags
we'll do a hot reload
and everything looks the same as it did
before because we've just done the same
styles were applied you can see this in
the dev tools we've got no class element
but there are those various properties
that have been created by tailwind for
us
okay so this is a very powerful feature
when you want to deal with these
repeated styles
so that's one way of dealing with with
repetition
and that one i would very much say is
like keep that to
things like uh that h1 example there
where you're just repeating the styles
it's nothing to do with repeated markup
all right
as we're using blader if we do want to
deal with repeated markup there's a
different technique we can use for that
it's where components come in okay
blazer like other spar frameworks
nowadays is all component based and
these are very powerful tools so that
tailwind panel that's on the right hand
side there that is actually on all of
the various pages so
what that means is we'd have the same
html structure repeated across all the
pages we'd have the same uh utility
classes applied to those and repeated
across all the pages
so
if we uh go and look at uh back into
visual studio we can deal with this as i
said just using a component so if i
create a tailwind uh component to
represent that
that markup
and then inside of there i can just
paste in the markup that's repeated
across the those three pages
so i can i can do that save that
i can get rid of the markup that's
that's there i can reference the
component
i can do that on the index page
uh come down here we'll get rid of it on
the fetch layer page as well
and finally we'll do on the counter page
as well
get rid of that
so i'm just referencing that component
across my my three pages
new components that's gonna do a new
little rebuild
cool and now i've got that markup
centralized i've got all those styles
centralized and i'm just referencing
that component across my app okay
so with these two techniques you can
pretty much remove all of the
duplication that you need to inside of
your app because there's not really many
other scenarios we're going to see
duplication you're either going to be
duplicating classes on an element or
you're going to be duplicating markup
with classes okay
and you can either use the the apply
directive
or components to deal with those
scenarios
cool
right
so
so far
we've kind of been dealing with the kind
of run-of-the-mill uh stuff that we need
to need to get our heads around in order
to start using tailwind so now
we're going to start delving into some
more interesting stuff
so what we're going to look at next is
animations
okay animations are
usually a bit painful if you're writing
blazer apps if they're usually going to
involve doing javascript interop of some
form or another
no that wouldn't be any good would it so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
show you how we can create a reusable
animated component that doesn't use any
javascript whatsoever we're going to do
this entirely with c sharp and tailwind
okay so what we're going to do
is on the home page just to add a little
bit more pop to it
we're going to have that panel
slide in from the right hand side okay
as the page loads it so i'm going to do
it once we're not going to like want to
give people headaches with this going
over and over and over here
but it's just going to add a little bit
of pop okay so let's go into
visual studio and let's have a look at
how we're going to do that so first off
we're going to start off by creating a
new component
so
i'm going to imagine we call this the
sliding component
and then let's have a look at the
initial code
so
in order to make this work we're going
to use a.net timer all right
and what we're also doing here is
creating what's known in blazer as a
templated component
now what this means is we're going to
wrap markup
and then we're going to use we're going
to take that markup that we've wrapped
and we're going to output it somewhere
inside of this component so that we can
do what we need to do um in blazer how
we do that is we create a parameter with
a name of child content it has to have
the name child content it also has the
type has that has to have the type of
render fragment that's a convention for
this to work and what we're saying is
whatever content we wrapped capture it
in this property and then we're going to
output it inside of this div that we're
we've got here in this component
okay
um and also i'm being i i realize this
is just a demo and a talk but i'm being
responsible here i do need to dispose of
my timer afterwards and someone very
kindly pointing this out on youtube that
i didn't do this previously so i've done
it now
so there's eye disposable on there and
i'm disposing of my timer
um
so
how is this actually going to work how's
the magic going to happen well
first of all we're going to add in some
base styles onto this this div here
in this particular case i'm going to
want the this div to be full height of
whatever element it's in so that's what
h fuller is doing for us
and then we get the fun stuff so
transition okay the transition property
what this is saying is whenever i change
a value of a css property i want it to
be transitioned over a period of time i
don't just want it to flip from one
value to another instantly
and i'm saying in the next class i'm
saying i want that duration to be 500
milliseconds so over half a second
and then i'm also using the transform
class which we saw earlier okay when we
skewed that element and that's because i
want to move
whatever elements we're wrapping around
a bit because i want to create this
slide effect
and then the last thing there is i'm
outputting whatever the value is of that
animated animation styles field that
i've got in my component and this is
really where the the sort of secret
source is we're going to dynamically
change the value of what's in that
animation styles and that's actually
going to help create this effect for us
so we now need to add in the default
styles for so this is what the animation
styles field is going to output when the
component first runs
so the first one is translate x full
now what this means is it's going to
move whatever markup we've wrapped on
the x-axis so horizontal axis it's going
to move at 100 of its width to the right
so if we just quickly go back to our
page what that's going to do is push
that panel off to the right of the
screen
the other one is opacity zero this is
just gonna make it transparent all right
it's still gonna take up physical space
in the dom it's not like i'm hiding it
or anything like that i'm just making it
invisible
so that's how it's going to start when
this component whatever it's wrapping
it's going to make it invisible and push
it off to the side or make it
transparent and push it off to the side
of the screen
so a little bit of
housekeeping here so we're going to new
up the timer i'm going to give it a
value of 300 milliseconds and then we're
saying when it elapses call this trigger
animation method okay which we haven't
added in so let's add that in now
and this method is the thing that's
going to alter that animation styles
what it's going to do is it's going to
get rid of the two classes that we've
added and replace them with translate x0
and opacity 100.
now it's quite important here to
understand that these are manipulating
the same css properties and this is
where having
that transition class is going to come
into play and 500 milliseconds because
what's going to happen
when this
trigger animation method runs
and blazer re-renders
and we get those new classes applied
because they're manipulating the same
css properties it's going to go right
translate x0 means render basically
render where you are rendering your
default position but we've pushed it off
to the left or off to the right sorry so
it's going to move it back over 500
milliseconds that's our slide effect
and also just to make it a little bit
more
whizzy
we're also going to then turn up the
opacity to 100 and again it's going to
happen over 500 milliseconds so it's
going to fade in so this is going to
create a slide and a fade effect for us
the final thing that we need to do here
is actually put in some code to start
the timer so we're going to do that
using the on after render lifecycle
method um it's important to use this
method because
we're going to make want to actually
make sure that everything's rendered
before we actually start anything going
we start the timer ahead of time it can
do some funky stuff um we're ensuring
this only runs once by putting it behind
this first render check okay
so once we've done that
we can uh go and see if our work is
going to bear any fruit so
let's
wrap this component
let's rebuild that
voila sliding component no javascript
done
um
so we'll just run that a couple more
times
just so you can see in action it's only
happening once it's coming through it's
definitely sliding um
so that's pretty cool we've now got a
reusable component that can slide stuff
in which we can use we could also extend
this if we wanted to you know you could
have additional parameters that
controlled
where it slides from so you can have it
slide from the right or the left or top
or bottom or whatever you want it to do
but the point here is i just want to
show you that you can do this stuff
by marrying these two technologies
together and you can obviously take this
away and
make it do even more funky stuff
the only thing here uh to point out
though is there's kind of one little
thing that niggles me at the bottom here
you can just see for a second or two
there is a scroll bar
and that's because the browser's being
very helpful for us it's going well
you've got this thing that's outside of
the viewport on the right hand side so
you probably want to see it so i'll get
you a scroll bar so you can get over
there and we don't really want that to
happen
so we can quickly fix this as well
inside of the host page what i'm going
to do is on the body tag here
i'm just going to say uh overflow x
hidden so it just doesn't show that
scroll bar so i'm going to save that
uh we'll do a hot reload it doesn't work
i have to refresh this i've done this
enough now that it kind of usually comes
out
still not doing it
i don't know why it never picks that one
up initially anyway
there we go so
we're now not seeing that scroll bar at
the bottom okay and we've now just got a
nice smooth
animation effect and you could do lots
of other types of effects with this you
know manipulating other things as you
see fit whatever your use case happens
to be
so
we'll move on to the last little big one
and that is dark mode dart mode's kind
of becoming almost a staple of
applications nowadays um as you can see
from my ui i'm i'm a fan of dark mode
it's kind of really been paining me that
my browser's in light mode at the moment
but there is a good reason for that
which we'll look at in a second
um so dart mode is something that
historically had to be turned on in
tailwind um with this new jit compiler
and the jit engine that's not the case
anymore it's there by default
and this is why my browser has been in
light mode because if we go into my
browser settings
i go to appearance and i put it back to
my system default we now have a dark
mode website now this is not magic i
have actually applied a load of classes
to do this don't think that wind is just
suddenly working this out for me um i've
already added them but um the point
being here is dark mode
the dart mode feature of tower wind is
on by default and it's based on whatever
your system preference is okay so
because my system preference is dark
mode it will apply dark mode classes if
they exist okay
you can see here at the top um that
navbar hasn't actually got any styles at
the moment so i thought we'll just go
through that one quickly together so we
can see what these look
like uh if we open up this so um
the key bits here are like uh the main
header element here has got a background
of white
these
nav links have text purple 700 is their
color
there's various other elements that
we're going to manipulate here um
so
if we just paste in the updated code in
order to get dark mode all we do is
create um similar to a hover effect we
just use the dark variant and we say
when it's dark apply this class instead
so i'm saying when i'm in dark mode
apply bg gray 700 instead of bg white
and you can see that just repeated
across the other elements so text purple
800 but when it's dark mode it's text
purple 400
right so if we save that we'll do a
reload and now we've got our dark mode
working on all of the bits and that goes
across all the rest of the site and and
all of this kind of stuff so that's all
working which is cool
um the only thing that's probably not
possibly as great as it could be about
this is what happens if you know you're
just having a light mode day you're
having one of those weird days where you
just want to burn your retinas and what
have you it'd be much better if you
could toggle this manually okay and you
can decide as a user whether you want to
see light mode or dart mode
on a particular day
so we're going to build a component
that's going to let us to do that let's
do this
um now we do need to change the default
dart mode configuration in tailwind in
order to make this work okay so that's
the first thing we're going to do
uh
if we go into our tailwind config
what we do here is pop in
for the dartmouth property we just
basically set it to class so that
overrides just detecting whatever the
system uh preferences are now if we uh
go and look back at our site now it's
gone back to light mode and the reason
for that is when we use the class mode
we have to have a class somewhere in the
html tree
called dark and then any child elements
from that element will have dark mode
classes applied to them so just to give
you a practical example of that if i go
to the html element here and i add dark
like so
all the dark elements all the dark
variants now get applied okay so that's
going to be what our component is going
to need to do it's going to need to add
and remove
that class of dark from the from the
html element
now in order to do this we are going to
use a little bit of javascript because
blazer can't actually get to that
element and manipulate it on its own so
we are going to use a little bit of
javascript in order to do that
so let's uh go in and have a look at how
we can do this so we're going to create
a new component
and this is going to be called
dark mode toggle
and let's pop in our class for that so
so up here in this block of markup this
is is what's going to actually create
the toggle component for us the look of
it
what we'll do is before we go any
further we'll just add this into the nav
menu and then we can just see what it
looks like first and i'll talk talk you
through it so
i will say dark mode toggle like so
save that
we'll do a reload
cool so this is basically what we've
created we've got this uh probably it's
quite common you've probably seen on
quite a lot of sites
um so how does this actually work or how
is it going to work
so we're using a kind of a usual trick
for creating sort of nicer looking html
controls here we've got a label that
wraps a div and that's using a four
attribute and then that is going to
toggle a hidden checkbox that we've got
okay
now what we're going to do is we're
going to hook on to that
that checkbox in our our blazer code in
order to
extract the value and and do whatever we
need to do with it so we're going to
hook on to the on change event so every
time that that value changes we're going
to call this toggle theme method
and then we've also got there's also a
dark mode uh private
boolean here and that's going to be used
to set the value of a checkbox all right
so if we've already got dart mode
selected we can reset it
cool so the first thing uh we'll do
quickly is we'll just get the javascript
bit out of the way so i'm going to use a
feature from blazer that came in in net
six which is called co-located
javascript so i'm gonna call this
javascript file dart mode toggle
dot razer dot js so it's the same name
as the component but just for the js
extension now if you're using visual
studio you get this like nice nested
effect
going on over there
and what's really what i really like
about it is it means that my javascript
lives with the component that uses it
which is i think much better from a
maintenance perspective
so
blazer supports javascript modules this
is javascript module um so we're just
exporting this one function called set
theme which takes a theme string and if
the theme is dark then we apply the dark
class and if it's not then we remove the
dark class okay that's that's all it's
doing and it's just doing it on that
html element that i showed you from the
dev tools all right so nothing overly
complex there we can kind of save that
often and kind of forget about that now
um so let's actually uh see how we can
use this module in our in our razor
component so the first thing we're going
to do is we need to import it into our
razor component all right so in order to
do that we need to create a field to
store a reference we can store
references to javascript objects in
blazer by using the ijs object reference
type
and then in on after render on the first
render we're going to go and we're going
to use the js igs runtime which is our
interface into javascript from from c
sharp code
and we're going to use that to go and
get that that module
in order to do that we use a certain
syntax we use the invoke async method we
set whatever the return type's going to
be so that igs object reference and then
the first argument is a special keyword
called import and then the second
argument is the path to that file that
we want to go and import from okay so
that's going to get us our reference to
our module
again because we're you know being a
responsible developer again
we're going to dispose of that correctly
because we've now got this reference
into javascript which we do need to
handle
so i'm going to use iasync disposable
for this one because it supports icing
disposable and called dispose async if i
need to so i've set that up
the next thing that we can do is update
this toggle theme method so
inside of here this is the method that's
going to get called by that hidden
checkbox okay every time that we we
change the value
so what we're going to do is in that
first line we're going to uh extract uh
whatever the value is whether it's true
or false if it's true dartmouth becomes
true otherwise false
and then
i've got this theme variable which is
going to if dartmouth is true then i set
it to dark otherwise i set it to light
and then i'm going to call that set
theme function in javascript and i'm
going to pass in that variable okay so
it's going to pass down the string of
either light or dark depending on on
what i've got set
cool so
let's say that we'll give a reload
let's have a look what happens now
cool so we have got
a switch that's loud let's go between
light and dark mode okay
if you're curious about that little
slide effect that's happening on the
toggle that's very similar to what we
did on the slide in component we built
earlier it's basically saying what
happens here is it says when it's dark
mode
uh transition it to the right by three
which is what it does to create that
slide effect okay
so
similar technique to what we use what we
used before so this is looking pretty
good the only downside here is if i if i
refresh the page it doesn't actually
save my my preference so
i think that's the last thing we can do
to kind of make this a little bit better
now
shameless plug here i'm using one of my
packages blazer local storage in order
to to interface with the browser's uh
storage apis um so i've injected that
i've installed the nuget package and
then injected the service
and then what we can do is after we we
set the theme
um we can just
um add that call to local storage and
what we're going to say is set uh a
theme key and then save whatever the
theme value is that we've got
so we can do that we can refresh
cool so we're in light mode if i go to
dart mode now and i hit refresh
okay it doesn't work
better play of course it doesn't work
i'm saving the value but i'm not reading
it out yet
so we'll deal with that
so after we load that module on the
first render we'll go off into local
storage and we'll try and get that theme
key okay
once we get that back we'll determine
whether we're
going to be applying light or dark mode
and then we'll call into that set theme
function in the same way passing in
whatever
whatever uh theme that we want
so with that done let's go and have a
look at our app
voila so it's remembered or it set dart
mode previously okay so that's why when
it's refreshed it's remembered it for me
so i can toggle back to light mode and
if i hit refresh it stays in light mode
and if i go to dart mode and i hit
refresh it stays in dark mode if we go
into the browser tools we can see here
that theme key being stored here in
local storage
cool so so everything's looking pretty
good um
so
we've gone through quite a few different
techniques here and how we can use
blazer and tailwind to create some cool
effects um
the last thing i kind of really want to
quickly show
is about how you can now go to
production with this how do you
make this work when you've got a ci
pipeline because obviously i'm running a
i'm running the cli using my terminal
and that's generating all these classes
as i go
but because that app css file it's it's
generating and putting in the in the wwe
root folder is dynamic you wouldn't want
to check that into your source control
okay so you're going to want your ci
pipeline to be generating that file when
it's doing a build of your application
now you've got you've got options here
one of one of the options is that you
could just add in a step into your build
pipeline to
run that mpx command for you
um
that's definitely one way of doing it um
the other way you can do um that we're
gonna look at now is to actually
leverage a bit of ms build so
i'm gonna open the project file here and
i'm gonna add in a couple of targets
into
uh into here so the first one is kind of
just a bit of kind of belt and braces
stuff um what that's going to do is it's
going to execute the npm minus v command
and if it if it basically doesn't get a
success code it's going to it's going to
fail the build and this is just to make
sure that npm is available wherever this
is being built okay
the second one is the it's kind of the
the interesting one
so um firstly it's going to run before
the application is compiled so this is
going to happen first then the main
build of the application will happen so
this is going to ensure that our css
file is available in order to be
packaged up with the rest of our app
um and we're going to execute that same
mpx command that we we did in the
terminal
we're going to pass in the input file
that style app.css and we're going to
have the output file
um
going into the wwe root folder as it was
before um the cool thing though is we're
going to
pass in this other flag this time
instead of doing minus minus watch we're
going to do minus minus minify
and that's because tailwind cli
supports minification out of the box
okay we haven't got to go and do any
other funky stuff in order to get that
work we can just pass in this extra flag
um
the other thing that we're doing here um
is setting the environment variable
though so we need this node m production
um environment variable um how we need
that in order for the minify stuff to
work
and finally we've got um some uh a check
here which is a dot net check and it's
saying that if we're it's only gonna
execute this if we're in release mode so
when we're running in debug mode um
during development time this isn't going
to run this isn't going to affect things
we'd just be letting our terminal deal
with that okay
so
that's what we're going to do uh so
we've added that in so if we just uh
what i'll do is i'll close all of these
and then we'll open out that output css
file
if i change this to release mode
and i rebuild the app in a second
hopefully if all's gone well
voila so it's really really tiny i
apologize i haven't zoomed this up but
first of all you can see npm versions
being output there it says
8.7.0
so that's that first target running and
then you can see that we've now only got
one line of css um and that's because
all of the minification processes
happened and all of our scale all of our
stuff has been minified nicely so we've
now got
a css file that only contains utility
classes that we use and it's all be all
been minified so we're using um the
least space that we uh we possibly can
cool so um yeah with that i think that
kind of brings us to a bit of a close so
um
if you do want any of the code or the
slides for this you can go to that url
at the top there and you can download
that from the git repo
um and yeah i think
yeah everything um thanks very much and
yeah if you want to ask questions
whatever please feel free to grab me
outside and thanks for coming enjoy the
rest of the conference everyone